hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones bonus video for
the week normally I'd do it on Sunday
but there's so much Walking Dead stuff
and Stephen Amell on SummerSlam so I'm
gonna be talking about the gravedigger
cleganebowl all about the Hound today
and Brooke quick reminder new round of
the giveaway starts now it's a $20
Amazon gift card all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video there been rumors
that Rory McCann the actor that plays
the Hound has been sighted in Belfast
but he hasn't been seen on the set or
anything like that so we don't know if
he's actually going to be in season 6
but it's totally possible he'd come back
if you remember way back in season 4 his
ending was kind of ambiguous it's it's a
situation like Stannis is in right now
where it's like you're pretty sure
they're dead but you're not sure most of
the theories about what happens to him
have been spun out of the books just
because there's so much more material so
many more characters and storylines
going on but even in the books it's
still not confirmed that he's coming
back so when people talk about the
gravedigger and they talk about
cleganebowl those are two theories that
depend on each other and they depend on
the context of the books but just
talking about the Hound coming back on
the show just assuming that you've never
read the books before they did see it a
couple clues that the story isn't
completely done with him yet he was
mostly invoked by arias storyline just
because he spent most of season 4 with
her so let's just start with the
gravedigger because that that theory
kind of spawns all the other theories
about the Hound coming back this is
taken from Brienne storyline in book 4
which has dramatically changed but the
show could do in season 6 so just
potential spoilers for the quiet Isle in
the gravedigger so if you remember back
in season 4 Brienne left King's Landing
on a mission to find the surviving stark
she had oathkeepers she got a new set of
armor and she got Podrick she does the
same thing in the books that just
happens at a different point in time but
during her journey she comes upon a
place called the quiet Isle now it's a
little island here at the mouth of the
Trident which is basically populated by
you know what you could consider monks
people who go to atone for their sins
they call them penitent the people who
have taken this vow of servitude
typically cover themselves up in
wrapping so you can't make out their
faces they're all relatively anonymous
well they're visiting the quiet Isle
they meet someone called the gravedigger
the reason that people think that this
mysterious gravedigger
is the hound is because the elder
brother who's kind of in charge of that
order of penitent knows way too much
about what the hound has experienced
like the pain that he is experienced in
his life for it to be a coincidence you
have to remember that this is like a
very obscure little tiny island it's not
like super famous in Westeros
there's plenty of other centers of
worship that you could go to to atone
for your sins Brienne also notices that
the gravedigger is bigger than her the
Hound is also bigger than her and she is
already one of the biggest people that
she has ever met there very few people
in Westeros that are bigger than her the
Hound in the mountain the wound that it
seems like he has the one that made him
lame is very similar like in a very
similar place to a wound that the Hound
sustained during book three when he was
at the end of the crossroads with Arya
Stark the tv-show kind of crossed that
encounter over with Brienne storyline so
like look the wound that Brienne gave to
the Hound would be the comparable one
that the gravedigger has in the books
then there's this dog a hound you might
say that follows the gravedigger around
that the gravedigger is very friendly
with and when the elder brother of the
order is talking to Brienne about the
death of the Hound he speaks in
metaphors as if say like the persona of
the Hound died and the person that lived
on is someone else so Sandor Clegane
might still be alive living under a
different name and if that weren't
enough the hounds horse stranger is also
seen on the quiet Isle
so all signs point to the Hound having
slinked to the quiet Isle to just forget
about his life as the Hound [ __ ] the
King [ __ ] the mountain [ __ ] everybody
peace I'm out of here kind of situation
so even if you guys haven't read the
books that sounds like a lot of evidence
that the Hound might still be alive just
living under an assumed name so that's
where we get into Clegane Bowl but let
me know like do you think that the Hound
is going to come back on the TV show do
you think that you know jack and
whacking Arya and her lying about
missing the Hound is a clue that he
might come back if the show does decide
to bring him back I would expect them to
do it in a slightly different way just
adjusting for the storylines that they
change from the books but there's a lot
of other characters that we're hoping
might come back taking on different
personas Jon Snow Prai being the biggest
one like they come back but they're not
the same person that died Jon Jon Snow
is just the extreme example then that he
literally died
so moving on to cleganebowl so now we
have to talk about what's going on with
Cersei in King's Landing in her trial
with the faith that was kind of left
hanging in the air at the end of the
season she did her penance walk but she
hasn't had her trial yet she still has
to have a trial she confessed to the
high Sparrow took the walk but that
wasn't like in exchange for the trial
like she still has to go on trial for
all the bad things that she's done she
believed confessing would just bring
about a more favorable outcome during
the trial it really remains to be seen
how long they're gonna drag this trial
situation out in King's Landing across
season six it could take the whole
season when we had Tyrians trial during
season four it took place over a number
of episodes but a lot of people are
hoping that Cersei chooses Robert strong
aka you know Franken Mountain asked her
champion in a trial by combat thinking
that he's unbeatable and she'll be able
to walk scot-free from whatever charge
they lay on her there really aren't that
many people that we know about in game
thrones that could beat the mountain
when he was whole now that he is Franken
Mountain he seems almost invincible so
who might come along that have a chance
to beat him well the Hound is just one
of those few people so a small portion
of the fandom thinking that the penitent
gravedigger who might be the mountain
will come back and be the faith's
champion during Circe's trial
therefore you wind up with Clegane
versus Clegane that that's cleganebowl
you guys can decide how you feel about
that I mean you know some of the
theories do line up but that's only when
you're looking at the context of the
book provides if he comes back on the
show there's really no precedent for a
cleganebowl the show's provided no
context for the mountain wanting to go
back to King's Landing to fight his
brother so if the show brings them back
and they do want to do this crazy
cleganebowl theory which I don't totally
buy into then they'd have to establish
motivation for the Hound going back to
King's Landing and right now I see no
reason for him to do that sure he hates
his brother but he doesn't care about
the rest of the kingdom and his brother
isn't a threat to the rest of the
kingdom
he's just Cersei as Gollum so as long as
his brother or Frankie man or however
you want to think about him doesn't come
and start pushing up on the Hound again
then there's really no reason for him to
care so you guys can let me know if the
Hound does come back on this show what
do you think that he's going to be doing
will he
get tied up in this Sansa plotline this
North remembers storyline do you think
that it will have anything remotely to
do with what's going on in King's
Landing really with with everything
they've changed so far I think his best
shot is to get tied up with what's going
on with Brienne Sansa in the North
remembers storyline again we don't know
how long it's gonna be before arias back
in Westeros so if they're gonna tie him
to Arya then he would have to wind up in
the east and that'd be a huge change
from the books so there there are a
number of different routes they can go
if they decided to bring the Hound back
just in case you guys didn't see it fear
The Walking Dead premiered last night on
AMC it's The Walking Dead spin-off show
they just announced that it shattered a
cable record that is like that one of
the most popular cable premieres in
history I think it was like 10 million
viewers just in the US now this is for
like a series premiere just for
comparison just for ratings comparison
in the u.s. just ticking US ratings
because they don't measure ratings
outside the US The Walking Dead Season 5
the main show premiered with like 17
little over 17 million viewers but it's
had about five seasons to build
popularity when it first premiered it
was a fraction of that it was way less
popular than fear The Walking Dead
started off with Game of Thrones Season
5 started with about 8 million viewers
the problem with that is is that HBO's
premium cable so fewer people get the
channel so the people that watch Game of
Thrones are every bit as passionate and
connected to the show as the people that
watch The Walking Dead it's just that
the Walking Dead is way cheaper to watch
so a lot more people get the channel but
if you're on the fence you should
totally watch fear The Walking Dead
there's six episodes in season 1 I'm
gonna be doing videos each week for it
I'm doing a weekly giveaway it's already
been confirmed for a 15 episode season 2
that'll start next year
so you can click here for my episode 1
video from that that I posted last night
and you can click here to learn all
about the life of the Mad King King
Aerys ii thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you